okay it's finally bouncy time after the
uh let's say controversial ending to the
wanokuni arc technically we have just
kicked off the next arc of the straw
hats adventure even though we of course
have no clue where we're gonna head next
and what's going to happen right now
we're back to full one piece glory and
there is a lot of stuff going on just as
you i'm a real sucker for whenever the
crew is simply hanging out on board of
the sunny and having a real good time
together even if it is without yamato
jinbe finally being an official part of
this all and seeing him interact with
everyone is something that i've been
waiting for
forever but the weight has more than
paid off it's fantastic having him be
part of the crew at this moment of
course we have to talk in detail about
the bounties of all the straw hats but
we also got an absolutely fantastic look
at the cross guild organization how it
was founded and why buggy once again
wasn't the secret genius that you
secretly wanted him to be admit it as
well with mihawk and dragon we have not
only one but two characters back in the
story that have a similar level of hype
around them whenever they pop up as our
red-haired papa pirates and i can't even
describe how excited i am to have sir
crocodile back in the game as well one
of the most intriguing and exciting
characters in all of one piece who by
the way correct me if i'm wrong
seemingly has grown significantly
stronger and powerful enough to play on
this big stage again really tell us that
mr zero is going to be a true force to
be reckoned with in the future actually
even though i can't wait to talk about
the straw hats and their bounties let's
start off with the cross guild after all
i have so many thoughts on everything
that has been revealed here oh also
maybe you think you already have but
please quickly check if you're already
subscribed it's free and it helps me a
lot make better content for you now
cross guild it turns out was purely the
idea of sir crocodile i mean we
basically got no updates on what the
most mafioso villain of one piece got up
to after the events at marineford well
turns out he wasn't just sitting around
enjoying a well-deserved cigar and
retirement i mean scheming to overthrow
an entire country is a lot of work let's
be real instead crocodile seems to have
waited for his chance to get back into
the big game once more the moment the
government declared the end of the
warlord system after the reveree and
started coming for the former
shichibukai crocodile took that chance
and made a call to his former warlord
colleague mihawk during that call he
offered him an alliance to join hands
and become a force that can play in the
game of finding the one piece
interestingly enough mihawk has accepted
this offer pretty fast he and crocodile
together are the actual bosses of this
new organization cross guild now i will
say that mihawk has a lot of these dot
dot dot speech bubbles here which
usually suggests some ulterior motives
in some way or form in other words
mihawk surely has his own reasons for
joining this alliance and there must be
something in it for himself and by the
way what is with mihawk's epic epithet
the marine hunter how cool is that we're
finally starting to get some real
background information about all those
mysterious legendary characters and it's
of course especially fun because as you
probably also thought it fits in very
nicely indeed with zoro's epithet of
pirate hunter i mean it really cements
their relationship maybe zoro's title
also played a role in mihawk sparing his
life and taking him on as his apprentice
i mean who knows he might even have seen
a younger version of himself in zorro
the pirate hunter who became a pirate
and the marine hunter who became a
marine
until he went back to hunting them let's
really hope that that's not some sort of
strange foreshadowing for zorro
we also finally get confirmation from
the marines that mihawk is a more
skilled
then shanks which you know kind of was
obvious i guess like after all shanks
isn't the strongest swordsman in the
world
mihawk is but i hope you agree that it's
really awesome as a line for both
characters i mean for mihawk it
basically confirms that he's able to
spar with someone on a yonko level and
is either very close to or even on the
emperor level i do want to say that
makes his performance at marineford
straight out root i mean he was
basically just chilling then but okay
whatever i think it's also pretty high
praise for shanks don't you think i mean
we have just gotten a real taste of his
next level hockey abilities far
surpassing anything we have seen from
any other character in the story so far
his congress hockey is even able to
cancel out people's future sites what
and so now we pretty much get
confirmation here that shanks is the
second strongest swordsman in the world
right now behind mihawk is that do i get
that correctly so not only is that man
an absolute hockey monster but also
capable of sparring on a level with the
world's strongest swordsman and he can
set his sword on fire apparently what an
absolute beast i hope we get to see
these two clash at least once in the
story even if it's only in a friendly
matter like please and then buggy really
just got entangled into this entire mess
in the most unlucky way imaginable when
he was about to run away from the
marines crocodile swept in and took all
of them out as it turns out buggy owed
him quite a lot of money like a lot lots
and since launching an organization like
cross guild that takes on the government
and hands out bounties on their heads
that takes a lot of financial resources
well crocodile had to come to bungie to
cash in on that debt i'm really dying to
know like i can't wait to find out when
and for what buggy borrowed so much
money for anyways the clown who of
course didn't have the money ready
offered the operations of his delivery
service to crocodile to use the existing
infrastructure as a starting point only
that uh buggies men of course who still
think that he is the most powerful
pirate on all the seas put out the
promotional poster for the cross guilds
without double checking with anyone and
of course he should be the leader of it
all right and thus buggy is now stuck on
karai body island kalaibati by the way
literally meaning bluffing in japanese
pretty fitting to everything that buggy
is doing there instead of taking him out
though crocodile and mihawk then decide
to have him be the official head of the
organization to draw attention away from
whatever they're doing and really it's
pretty funny to see that all of buggy's
inner circle is there and they're all
completely fine with all this because
they all know all too well that buggy is
really just one big fraud love the
dynamic here and so the question now of
course is what do crocodile and mihawk
really want do they want to go for the
one piece do they just want to live a
good life without having to fear the
marines or do they want something else
entirely when it was still unclear
whether or not buggy might not actually
be the leader of this organization well
i personally thought it was possible
that cross guild would be a real threat
to luffy on a level equal to blackbeard
even maybe but now seeing that this
turned out to be wrong once again i
personally like to think that cross
guild might end up being more of an ally
than an enemy to the straw hats really i
mean for one i'm a massive fan of the
crocomom theory i actually made a whole
video about it so if you don't know what
i'm talking about right now really make
sure to check it out but even if
crocodile does not turn out to be
luffy's mom he still actively protected
luffy and risked his life for him during
marine fort where by the way he also
clashed with a certain mihawk
and of course while zorro and mihawk
should absolutely fight at some point in
the story there's still a real
relationship here between a teacher and
a student mihawk made zoro what he is
today and sees him as a worthy candidate
so i really hope we get to see regular
updates on all of these three regularly
from now on because i am super hyped to
see where all of this is going with the
cross guilds i also quickly wanted to
address the ongoing subplot surrounding
the germa on whole cake islands i for
one am really excited that caesar is
back and i'm really curious where all
these characters will be fleeing to next
and i also hope that it will lurk how to
curry back into the world as well i need
that man back in the story but for now
let's move on to the revolutionaries all
the commanders who infiltrated marijuana
and faced off against two of the
admirals have now returned to kamabaka
islands the new headquarters of the
revolutionaries it's a really cool scene
here seeing kuma and dragon talking but
kuma still is full cyborg slave mode
here sadly so it will take someone like
chopper or frankie or who knows dr
vegapunk himself maybe to turn him back
into a real human being i think and i'm
also extremely curious if bonnie is with
him or not i was actually surprised how
harshly dragon was also talking here
about sabo did dragon have some sort of
connection or relationship to king cobra
or is he simply appalled at the thought
of sabo killing someone which you know
yeah isn't nice but he did send his
troops to invade the most powerful
institution and the gathering of the
world's kingdoms i mean someone could
get hurt anyways we do see sabo calling
koala so i do hope we get a continuation
of this next time i really want to know
where sabo is what happened and whether
or not vb is with him because now would
of course be the perfect time for vivi
to rejoin with the straw hats which of
course brings me all the way back to the
thousand sunny as the straw hats are
leaving the waters of wano i find it
hilarious that oda sensei by the way
basically bullied his two new emperors
in this chapter at the same time because
apparently nami has locked luffy up in a
metal cage for steering the sunny down
the edge of wanos borders understandable
but why the heck does she have that
thing in the first place that's a bit
concerning jinbei who is really hanging
with the straw hat crew for the first
time outside of a major battle situation
laughs at nami's anger outbreak only to
get shut down really fast by one of
nami's anger outbursts now this scene
here jimbei says is that conquest hockey
and i bet there will now be a massive
debate whether this is real or not i
mean oda sensei did draw these tiny
black lightnings from nami as well i
personally still think this is more of a
joke here but then again who knows maybe
it's foreshadowing for nami actually
having conquerors hockey at some point
later on in the story might explain her
sixth stance for reading the weather as
well so that would be something else for
sure and poor sanji really because he
didn't get any so far so as a quick
recap here are all the updated bounties
of the straw hats luffy we of course
already know 3 billion that's a bit less
than mihawk's 3.5 million but quite a
bit more than crocodiles 1.9 chopper has
gotten the biggest increase 10 times his
previous bounty
but it's still only at 1 000 berries
poor guy
nami has 366 million which is more than
luffy had at marineford pretty damn
impressive brook has 383 and frankie
394 million which i found a little bit
unfair i mean both brook and frankie are
way more powerful than most people give
them credit for both of them were more
than ready to keep fighting and barely
took any damage as far as i can remember
so i think they could have deserved a
little bit more but it's still pretty
impressive usopp has now finally caught
up with his god usa market worth on
dresrosa and is at 500 million berries
which is awesome especially given his
really intense reaction to it robin's
bounty is really interesting i actually
did predict that she would have a really
high one i mean yes she is strong and
apparently has awakened her devil fruit
and hockey at this point question mark
but it's of course also mostly due to
who she is the last survivor of a horror
and probably the only person so far as
we know able to decipher the ponoglyphs
with
930 million she's just short of that 1
billion barry mark which i personally
guess oda sensei did to distinguish the
top 3 fighters in the crew sanji jinbei
and zoro who are all really close to
each other sanji with 1 billion and 32
million jimbei with 1 billion and 100
million and zaro with just 1 100 so
basically one chopper more than jinbe
giving him barely the number two spot
behind luffy i mean sanji was slightly
above zorro last time and now it's the
other way around and the banter between
these two
just the best like this chapter is
classic one piece fantastic zara of
course teasing sanji with being number
four love it and all those little
details like sanji bursting completely
into flames in his anger i mean even
though the dynamics in the crew haven't
changed the slightest each and every one
of the straw hats are now absolute
monsters there's no other way of putting
it a truly powerful yonko crew i mean
can they get any stronger even well
absolutely i think oda sensei has shown
that luffy can still grow in terms of
his own devil fruit his hockey abilities
and even the voice of all things if you
want to know what luffy's next power up
will look like well you shouldn't miss
out on this video here at any cost like
watch this like you should absolutely
not
not miss out on it